[Music]
you may have heard about this it's a
crazy situation for the third time in
just over a month three different
african-american men have been arrested
in Florida for eating another man's
flesh this is a story this is getting a
lot of attention
it's a crazy trend right now in this
country here to comment is one of our
writers Deon Cole
thanks Conan so let me nip this in the
bud right now the answer is no all black
men do not want to eat white people some
of y'all might be tasty too but that
ain't the point the fact is that black
people do not want to chow down on your
flesh and I don't want people to stop
making this no new stereotype neither
are we clear
okay well then if I can just comment for
a moment I really don't think you need
to worry about others stereotyping black
people as flesh eaters I mean these were
these were all isolated incidents
involving illicit substances that alter
these people State of Mind these three
cases don't make up a racial trap
I'm sure America is more open-minded to
the individual facts of each case
in fact in Canada or what person was
accused the very same crime just a few
weeks ago I think it ought to worry
about a thing so thank you very much
Dion and thank you cheeseburger
every day
[Applause]
[Music]